- Hello, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
Welcome to the first episode
of "Planet Slow Mo."
For the next 12 weeks,
we're gonna be travelling
around the world
to all kinds
of exotic locations.
We've separated each episode
into two parts.
In part one,
we'll travel somewhere
we've never been before,
film something
pretty wicked in slow-mo.
And in part two,
we'll take a deeper dive into
the science of what we've shot
and analyze our footage.
For the first episode,
I thought we'd go
somewhere cool.
I like it,
I like what you've done there.
( music playing )
Today we're on a glacier
in Iceland.
- Where's that?
- That's in Iceland.
- That makes sense.
- Makes sense.
Yeah. So wait,
if we're on a glacier,
does that mean we're already
moving in super slow-mo?
Yeah, this is literally
the perfect place for us.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna travel
around Iceland
and film some of
its natural beauties
in some lovely 4K 1,000
frames a second slow-motion.
And it should look lush.
Mm. Should we start
with the geyser?
Start with the--
which way is that?
Actually, I don't know.
There's not really
any identifiable...
Should we just head in a
direction and hope for the best?
Yeah, let's go
to the white.
All right, yeah.
- ( grunts )
- ( laughs )
Oh, you Muppet.
( music playing )
This is
the Strokkur Geyser.
You nailed
that Icelandic.
Thank you.
Or if you're English,
- the Strokkur Geyser.
- Man: Whoo!
Or if you're American,
"Guy-zer."
- Whatever, right?
- Is that right, "guy-zer"?
Yeah.
- We're all correct.
- Yeah.
It goes off every
five to ten minutes.
And we've seen it hit
40 meters in the air.
- It's gone really high.
- Really high.
- Yeah.
- So we're gonna whip out
the Phantom Flex 4K
and get some lovely
1,000-frames-a-second shots
of it going off.
Smells a bit like eggs.
Sorry,
that was me that one.
- Oh, was that you?
- Yeah.
Gav: All right, here we are.
Filming in the rain,
bit of a mare.
Uh, why won't-- oh!
- Oh!
- That was a good one.
That was a bloody good one.
( music playing )
Dan: Oh, that's big there,
look at that!
Gav: That is massive.
Dan: That's huge.
It's almost coming out
the side.
Came out at like four different
places at once there.
Gav:
Got some height on that one.
Wow, that was a great one.
How wicked.
- That was wicked.
- That was perfect.
That particular one there
was a really bubbly one.
That might be the bubbliest
one that I've seen.
It sort of like
slowly does it
and then
eventually explodes.
Sometimes it just
goes straight up.
- Should we watch that back?
- Yeah.
Gav: All right, playing back.
- Ooh!
- Okay, look at that.
- God.
- It's really blue under there.
It looks like a giant,
it's just explosion
underneath all the water.
And then it finally--
see where it breaks the tension
- of the water there?
- Yeah.
- That was cool.
- Gav: It's wherever
the gas comes out
of the bubble first,
that's where it rushes out
and then it immediately
drains the bubble.
Dan: Yeah, the bubble
just gets drained.
Seems like
it's completely random.
- Totally random.
- It's just based on
what bubble comes up.
Yeah.
( people clamoring )
Gav: I want to be really tight
on that bub.
Dan: And that bub was good.
Where's it break?
Oh, there it goes
- Dan: ( hisses )
- ( chuckles )
Dan: It's quite a bit of,
like, surface tension it seems.
Really gets quite big
before it explodes
and then it just loses it.
I feel like it'd be
really good if we got...
the top down,
like looking...
- Ah, I'll stop you there.
- Yeah?
- I got it covered.
- All right.
- I've been working
on something.
- Okay.
- Right then.
- Phantom with a drone.
Right, so by working on it,
you mean you've tied your drone
to the Phantom with string.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Are you concerned with
the weight of the Phantom
and the fact that it's got
a massive, heavy lens on it?
- No.
- No, it'll be fine, right?
- Yeah.
- All right, let's give it a go.
Okay, here we go.
This is typically
a no-drone area,
but we have got
special permission.
Stand back.
( grunts )
Come on!
- Come on!
- Dan.
Dan, I'll stop you there.
I'll stop you there.
I've got something
different in mind.
All right.
Why don't you look up?
( fanfare )
- Well, hello.
- Hello.
This is the biggest drone
I've ever seen.
You want to
tell us about it?
It is probably one of the
largest commercial drones
in the world
for aerial photography.
Of all the Phantoms
we've ever used,
this is the biggest one.
The biggest Phantom? Yeah.
Dan: We've also got
a bunch of other stuff
that's not supposed
to be on there.
The household router there.
We can't trail a long
BNC cable from a drone
so we have a Wi-Fi router
and then using an app on
my phone to trigger the camera.
We also have full lens control,
so that's nice.
The batteries
are powering the drone,
the router,
the camera and everything,
so you haven't got
much flight time.
What's our flight time
today, do you think,
- off one set of batteries?
- Around eight minutes.
Dan: So I would say
it's Jerry-rigged completely.
- Yeah.
- Can't trigger it normally.
- And it's pretty much
not ideal conditions
in any way.
Well, and we're flying it
right over a giant water spout.
Yeah, I guess there's
a water hazard as well.
Yeah. Right, I say
we get it up in the air.
Let's do it.
That's a lot of money
in the air right now.
Dan: It really is.
Is that the riskiest position
our Phantom's
ever been in?
Probably.
Got it, got it, sweet.
Bring it back in.
( chuckles )
Change batteries.
I like his jacket.
"Drone pilot, do not interrupt."
Dan: I want one of those
just for everyday life.
Oh, yeah, there it is.
Nice.
You can see more of
the bubbles coming up.
Gav: Yeah, you can see
down the spout hole.
Dan: Yeah.
Do you think we should get one
where there's slightly less
of this foreground,
a bit more headroom?
- If we shoot more this way...
- Yeah.
...we'll have more
mountain to...
- That's a good point.
- ...before it hits the sky.
Dan: I like it.
( chuckles )
Maybe further back just a touch.
- Jon: Over here?
- Oh, that's great.
- Good?
- That's really good.
Whoa, yeah.
( grunts )
Got it.
Let's play it from here.
Dan: It was like beefy
right at the climb.
Gav: That's trippy.
Pfft. Oh.
Ooh, yeah.
Dan: It came out like sideways,
you see?
- It did, yeah.
- It didn't go straight up,
it's kind of beefy
and came out sideways.
Gav: That's a fat height.
- Like a double one, wasn't it?
- Yeah.
It makes a difference
being up this high
because we've got
the backdrop of the trees,
which is easier
to see the spray.
Yeah, that's something
we couldn't get
from the ground level, is it?
Because the sky is so white,
there was no difference
in contrast,
but that is lovely,
that's a real good visual
of how high it goes.
The fact that it
cleared the mountains
- from that point of view.
- Yeah.
Gav: You know what
I think we should do?
Like look
right down the hole.
Do you know what?
I don't think--
No one has ever
seen that before.
When would that have
happened before with--
Like, that would never be...
- I don't know.
- That'd be cool.
- Has it happened before?
- Might've.
Oh, we'll do it anyway.
I think we should, yeah,
I think we should look
right down the blowhole.
Yeah.
I'm nervous for his drone
and the camera.
- Should we go higher? 'Cause...
- No, that's good.
Yeah, but I'm saying
that like...
Might get hit.
Right.
This shot should be money.
Do you reckon you could
go a bit higher?
That's pretty low.
Dan: Ooh!
Jesus Christ!
Holy crap.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Took an absolute washing.
All right, hold on.
Oh.
( sighs )
We put the camera
in some risky positions before.
Above a boiling hot geyser
is probably one of the riskier
places it's ever been.
Is it playing on there?
Oh, you can see it coming
from so far down.
Dan:
How deep do you think that is?
Gav: I think it's at least
40 meters deep.
It's pretty deep.
It's like the Earth's sneeze.
Dan: Yeah.
Gav:
Yeah, there's the start of it.
It absolutely
soaked the camera.
Water that went all up it.
And then I was like,
"Get it out of there!"
And then it
all came on down.
It was like...
it's getting it again.
Oh, it was intense.
It's just complete whiteout.
Dan: You can see the individual
drops there still.
Gav: That's straight
in the mouth of the camera.
Dan: Camera doesn't know
what it's seeing right now.
Well, I feel very lucky that
we've got all these shots
and we haven't binned
the camera or the drone.
- Well...
- So...
- Well, we got it wet.
- Well...
Eh, completely soaked it,
but, yeah.
But why don't we move
to a different location?
- Okay. Yeah.
- Sound good?
Well, look at this,
here we are
at a lovely new location.
That's right,
we're at the "Gunfoss..."
Gun...
What is it?
Hold on.
What's this...
what's this waterfall called?
Gullfoss.
- Gu...
- Gullfoss.
Gul... Gullfoss.
All right, thanks, cheers.
The Gull...
The Gull... what he said
waterfall, okay?
The what-he-said
waterfall.
And we're gonna put the camera
back on the drone,
and get some lovely slow-mo
shots of the water.
- Yeah.
- We know him,
don't worry about it.
Come on.
That is so far away.
Dan: It's far.
( music playing )
Gav: The sun is setting on
another lovely day of slow-mo.
That was actually
an interesting one because,
even though it didn't require
anything from us subject wise,
we decided to film it in
the most difficult way possible.
Yeah, let's just put
the Phantom in the sky
and film it from there.
- Yeah.
- And it may have got
a little bit wet,
but thankfully
we still got a Phantom
and a lovely drone.
Hopefully you enjoyed
that video.
Feel free to subscribe
to the Slow Mo Guys
and check out part two
and other episodes
of "Planet Slow Mo."
Thank you very much
for watching.
Bloody love Iceland.
- It's gorgeous.
- Yeah.
- So nice.
- Could stay here an extra day.